we turn to other disturbing news
surrounding joe biden he hasn't held a
single press conference he has no plans
to give a state of the union address
his vice president has apparently taken
over the duties of talking one-on-one
and having these meetings with world
leaders in last week
during rare public appearance biden
struggled and i mean
struggled mightily take a look
i promise you we are going to together
beat this
and uh and i think that i
you know but the idea that um
over 500 i have a card i carry a
card with me every day
with the total number of folks who have
been affected by
the uh
as of uh yesterday
there were 500 071 people have died from
this
what else is on the card that was not a
hard number to remember because they had
a vigil the day before
my name is joe my wife's name is jill i
live at 1600 pennsylvania avenue
this is getting scary over the weekend
it got worse during some rambling
remarks
he completely forgot what he was talking
about and
well i think congresswoman sheila
jackson lee is pretty well known
and her name's not shirley take a look
i want to thank you governor miss abbott
for your hospitality and your friendship
and uh representing senator cornyn i
think he had to go back
uh i think he was getting on a plane he
told me a little lassie came in to see
me last event
and representatives
cheryl shirley jackson lee al green
sylvia garcia lizzie pinelli
excuse me panel and uh what am i doing
here
i'm gonna lose track here and
what am i doing here her name is sheila
jackson lee congresswoman sheila jackson
lee according to the report
in the hill there are now whispers that
biden's chief of staff ron klain is
actually running the show
and while joe naps remember he's looking
he's talking he looks so
exhausted uh i carry a paper with me to
remind me every day
just go back four years ago and look at
tapes in jail go back 10 years ago
which brings us to a very serious but
real necessary question
is joe biden is this far worse than we
were ever told
is he fit to serve because these are the
same questions the democrats the media
they had no problem asking about ronald
reagan the age question they called it
in the late 80s or about john mccain
during his presidential campaign
the media the democrats they all talked
about it openly
given what we now see from joe biden day
after day after day
this is now a fair question that needs
to be asked joining us now with more
former white house aide
to the trump administration also
president trump's
leading speech writer uh steve miller is
with us all right let's talk about the
joke question then we'll quickly go to
the transition of the speech
um this is look i i we used to get
criticized when i said weak frail and
struggling cognitively i'm not getting
criticized any longer you know why i
think that is stephen
because everybody sees it
this would be comical sean if it weren't
so truly
terrifying the question is who is
actually making the decisions running
this country right now
i mean who made the decision to start a
border crisis in the first month of this
presidency
who made the decision to rejoin the
paris climate accord
stop the keystone pipeline shut down
energy production nationwide
who made the decision to start funding
abortion overseas with your taxpayer
dollars
clearly somebody's making all these
decisions and it's not joe biden
and it's affecting real lives and real
people and we're entitled to answers
yeah i i totally agree all right let me
move on so
what i liked a lot now at cpac 97
support for the president's policies
that kind of tells you the direction of
the party
all right i think those in the
establishment wing that think that that
that
that the party's going to go backwards
away from the trump
america first make america great again
gender are wrong
the agenda is what it is and it's fairly
simple
now the president spelled all of that
out and he also added to it
the things that we have to fix with
elections so people have
confidence and integrity in our election
process and is very clear on that as
well
he gave a powerhouse speech sean that
rallied republicans and rallied
conservatives
around the values that are going to win
the midterms and win the white house in
four years
and he was especially effective and
lacerating
in condemning joe biden's cowardice on
school reopenings
children are hurting across this country
and i
applaud president trump just as a
citizen for saying what needed to be
said get the schools open get our kids
back in school
is joe biden so terrified of the
teachers unions
that he's going to sacrifice literally
the futures of
millions of young kids all across this
country
it needed to be said and donald trump
said it and he said a lot more
about our economy about energy about
recovery
about covid and he was especially
effective in my view
in him in his detailed takedown
of joe biden's border policies and what
he's done along the southwest border
where we had a secure border and now we
have an unprecedented crisis
what you saw with that speech was what
every republican needs to be doing
nationwide
in a factual detailed issue-by-issue
rebuttal
of the first month of the most left
administration we've ever seen
well said all right steve miller thank
you appreciate you being with us